Hi, my name is Matt Cail and on behalf of Expert Village I'm gonna show you how to make a princess costume.
The most challenging part of our princess costume hunt is going to be the dress.
The dress is the centerpiece of your costume...
...and it's also gonna be the most difficult to find just the right dress that's going to work for you.
Now, don't build this up into a wedding, it's not like your wedding dress after all.
But it is still a very important element of your costume.
It will be the one people remember about your princess costume.
So, what can we do to find a good dress?
There are a couple of options.
First off, the longest one.
If you are very talented in terms of clothes making,...
...if you have a lot of time and if you have access to some good fabrics,...
...either fabrics that you already own...
...or through a fabric store nearby to get some good material, you can always make a dress.
People have done this.
They've often turned out into really great costumes.
The people that take them on generally know what they're doing.
But again, this is gonna take a lot of time.
A lot of time, a lot of patience and probably a lot of fittings on whoever's gonna be the princess.
Oddly enough, a lot of people who end up being princesses rarely make their own dresses.
So a more practical idea is as I previously mentioned, consider getting a dress from somewhere.
You can even rent some.
This could be a good option to get something that is very neat looking...
...that you're only gonna really be wearing for one evening.